you might want to keep an extra eye on  your way this long weekend as it seems  spontaneous combustion is the thing you  might need to worry about things got a  little heated at the Pellegrin residence  in Colorado Springs when a wii console  burst into flames from the inside fire  investigators have said that the wii is  the most likely cause of the fire inside  of the RV home and that it originated  from within the console itself and not  from the wiring damaged in the fire were  pelegrin TV some clothes and the wii it  self along with extensive smoke damage  to the ceiling fortunately Pellegrin was  not at home when the fire occurred and  an adjacent xbox 360 has escaped  unscathed Pellegrin has attempted to  contact Nintendo regarding the not so  welcome feature of his ex console but at  the current time he's received no  response that we know of as always do be  cautious with your electronics and stay  tuned to gamespot for more updates and  gaming catch stories  you